le paysage entre newport et new york
étaient d'absolument incroyable offrant
en 1h30 de vol
une sorte de résumé de l'amérique en
dehors de cette vision aérienne de ses
contemporains marque s'inquiéter ils se
demandaient comment tout ceci allait
finir
alors une femme de choix jacques sauvage
c'est un roman à suspense
mais qui parle surtout d'une femme une
femme de choix puisque c'est le titre ça
se passe aux etats-unis dont votre
passion pour les états unis
on voit ici chez vous mais aussi c'est
surtout un regard sur les salles oui
c'est en fait le thème du livre lorsque
j'ai décidé d'écrire ce troisième qu'un
je vais parler de la force des femmes et
faiblesses des hommes et celui pour
illustrer sa que je sois percutant que
ce soit quelque chose qui qui tiennent
la haute et qui donne envie aux gens de
liens
je veux en faire un roman polar au début
qui ensuite va de plus en plus
intéressés à ces fameux rapport affectif
à ces rapports entre les hommes et les
femmes et cerexhe
on le voit sur la pochette c'est très
clairement exprimé la femme en talons
aiguilles qui la femme aussi en basque
est la même la même
absolument les femmes sont multiples
mais sont surtout capable de pardon
elles sont capables de pardon ils ont
une force incroyable
elle doit une énergie redoutable elles
ont une volonté qui nous dépasse je
pense par moments et surtout l on voit
dans le roman ce personnage qui ont donc
qui donc se fait enlever par un mauvais
sujet elle utilise toutes ses forces
toute son énergie
me ferait ch et y tuer on ne va pas
dévoiler la fin non il ya une phrase
peut-être qui résume ce livre je sais
pas si vous serez d'accord chacun
regarde sans voir ce qui le dérange ou
l'affect oui c'est terrible on est dans
un monde aujourd'hui où il ya des choses
qu'on ne veut pas voir et des choses qui
qui transparaissent obligatoirement et
que l'on se refuse à admettre et à
chacun ensuite de savoir la conclusion à
la conclusion
elle est formidable dans ce livre de
jacques sauvage qui s'appelle une cible
de choix on rappelle que vous êtes aussi
à la radio sur france bleu avec deux
émissions talents d'ici et puis aussi
talents d'ici tous les jours 14h40 18h40
qui traite de l'actualité musicale de la
région et puis yeux sur la route un
reportage toutes les semaines qui
diffusée du lundi au vendredi à 6h50 et
ne leur car et vos fut le patron
il fut un temps c'est un temps mais
chacun son temps et aujourd'hui vous
êtes écrivain une femme de choix roman
formidable que je vous conseille ici
pour lens à bouche merci jacques merci
des livres et musique maintenant avec
l'italie qui débarque à deauville 58 et
60 rendez-vous lectures concerts
rencontres débats
et c'est gratuit du 16 au 18 avril à
deauville ciao